festival marks its fifth year this
weekend with writers artists scholars
journalists filmmakers and about town
excursions and now to Times Square
studios for live coverage of Malcolm
Gladwell The New Yorker writer and the
tipping point author previews his next
book blink the power of thinking without
thinking you are watching live coverage
of the New Yorker festival on book TV
Oh
identifying an enemy
yeah okay
hello if everyone can hear me my name is
Henry fender I'm the editorial director
of The New Yorker magazine and I'd like
to welcome you to the fifth annual New
Yorker festival a message here to say -
please turn off any cell phones or
pagers devices Malcolm will be speaking
for about 40 minutes we'll have 20 30
minutes of Q&A after that during the
question period they'll be microphones
down the aisle and we request that you
would line up and speak into the
microphone during that time Malcolm
Gladwell has been a staff writer for The
New Yorker magazine since 1996 before
that it was the New York bureau chief
for the Washington Post
at The New Yorker very quickly made his
mark establishing a new genre of story
the Malcolm Gladwell story and there
very few people like that in the 80
years of this magazine at editorial
meetings the subject may come up and
somebody will say oh that's been done to
death someone else will say yeah but if
we if we have a kind of Malcom Gladwell
take on it it's a great conversational
trump card Malcolm has a really a
peculiar genius for explanation
sometimes very peculiar and and it's
tempting to try to explain what makes
him such an important writer I think I
think a lot a lot of it has to do with a
certain originality of mind a certain
distinctiveness of voice and I think
both of those qualities were on display
in his best-selling book the tipping
point which is a book that's been quoted
by at least one u.s. president by Joint
Chiefs of Staff by CEOs by
philanthropists oh yes it's also the
title of a new album by the hip hop band
the roots it was their homage to their
intellectual hero
his his new book is coming out in
January it's called blink the power of
thinking without thinking I've never
actually seen Malcolm when he wasn't
thinking so I'm curious to see how he's
gonna pull it off anyway
please welcome
Thank You Henry in nine years of editing
me that's the that's the kindest Henry's
ever been talking about our relationship
I'm very happy to be here in too happy
to see all of you and guessing that most
of you are here because you couldn't get
into the sai Hirsch evening last night I
think I got assigned his overflow which
is fine although I should say that if
any of you are here expecting to get
some major blockbuster earth-shattering
revelations about American foreign
policy you are in the wrong place The
New Yorker is divided into serious
writers end whimsical writers or as we
like to say sometimes into dinosaurs and
cartoon dinosaurs and sy Hersh is a
dinosaur and I'm I'm a cartoon dinosaur
I was told that I'm supposed to talk
about my new book which is called blink
which is as Henry said coming out in
January and I hope that all of you buy
it in triplicate at that point it's it's
about the power of thinking without
thinking and it's really about what
happens in the first two seconds of any
encounter between a person and a person
or a person and an idea or a person in a
situation so far the book has been
reviewed twice by those early review
services one of which said that it was
quite good and yellow which said it was
an utterly forgettable piece of
juvenilia so the the question of its
merits is still up in the air but I hope
it's resolved by the time January comes
around but I want to tell you a story
from the book it's one of my favorite
stories in the book and it's I think
it's a pretty good introduction to what
this book is about and the kinds of
questions that I'm trying to address in
blink and it's something that happened
five years ago I think that something of
story that all of all of us in New York
remember but I think that not all of us
is particularly at the time in New York
adequately understood and it's the story
of amadou diallo
now Diallo was from Guinea in Africa he
was a recent immigrant was 22 years old
and he was short he's about five foot
five or five foot six quite slight I
tell you those facts because not because
I'm warming up to tell a story but
because these kinds of facts the
smallest details of this case are
absolutely critical in understanding
what happened that night on one of the
faults that I have with the way that we
came to learn about that story and
understand that story is that it was
interpreted as a story about grand
themes about racism about Police
Department's about the status of this so
that in America and it is not a story
about grand themes it's a story about
details so these little details that I
start with are as I said absolutely
central to understanding what exactly
happened that night
Deanna lived in a part of the Bronx
called sound view and sound view is in
the north in the southeastern Bronx and
it's in the late 1990s it was a pretty
bad neighborhood there's a major
open-air drug market that had just been
shut down about about two or three
blocks over from where Deanna lived they
all lived on a street called wheeler
Avenue and wheeler Avenue was one of the
little streets that comes down off the
main thoroughfare which is Westchester
Boulevard and it's a very very narrow
street of two-story red brick row houses
built around the turn of the century and
they're very close to the street there's
a sidewalk there's no grass strip in the
sidewalk it's just Street sidewalk two
quick steps and then you have these
buildings these two-story buildings and
Deanna lived in one of these on the
second floor and on the night of
February 3rd 1999 he comes home from he
was a peddler he sold one of those guys
on 14th Street who sells gloves and
scarves and hands and he comes home
around midnight and he goes upstairs and
he talks to his roommates and then for
reasons we don't know he comes
downstairs again maybe he wanted to have
a cigarette
maybe he want just to take in the night
air maybe he was feeling claustrophobic
we don't know he comes downstairs and he
stands in the vestibule of his building
now the vestibule of his building is
very small it's probably no more than
this wide and it's probably no more from
the
of this stage back to about where I am
now and he's standing right on the edge
looking out in the street and as he's
standing there car drives by down
wheeler Avenue Ford Taurus unmarked for
people in it and therefore plainclothes
police officers who are part of the
NYPD's street crime unit which is a
special unit that have been set up in
the late 1990s basically to break up
things like open-air drug markets
there's four guys in this car Sean
Carroll Ken boss Richard Murphy ad
McMillan they're all in their mid 20s
and early 30s and they're green these
are not experienced police officers
they're all dressed in jeans and
sweatshirts they got bulletproof vests
under so their chests are kind of puffed
out and I got baseball caps and I got
regulation 9-millimeter handguns a
pancake holster right cruising down
wheeler Avenue and the crews buy and
they seed yellow and Carroll says hold
up hold up who's that guy there what's
he doing there right now
Carroll says later that he thought that
Diallo was by one of two things he
thought maybe he was a rapist who
they've been looking for in that area
for some time because it had been a
rapist who've been very active about a
year before I never caught him his
second thought that was that Diallo was
a lookout for a pushing robber pushing
robbers or the guys who come to an
apartment building hit all the buttons
until someone lets them in and then they
go in and they knock on the door and
just basically if someone answers it
push the way in right well they often
head of a lookout on the ground floor to
alert them to the presence of other
people coming in the building or cops so
he thinks it's one of those two things
maybe that's the thought that goes to
his head so they drive by then they stop
the car boss is driving and they back up
and Carroll and McMillan get out of the
car and Carroll opens up his wallet
shows his ID and says police officers
can we have a word right now Diallo
unbeknownst to them doesn't speak much
English he's a very very recent
immigrant from Africa he also is a very
bad stutter so he's inclined in many
situations not to talk at all and
thirdly one of his friends several
months before had been robbed by a
series of people by number by a group of
people posing as police
so he's terrified by these guys right so
here yet he's on a dark street right
sitting there taking the night air in
front of his house for big guys way
bigger than him with big puffed out Ches
white guys in the middle of the South
Bronx right come at him boom out of his
car and speak in a language he may or
may not only completely understand so
he's standing in his small vegetable he
sees these guys and he turns around and
it goes back to go back into his house
turns around puts his hand on the door
and Carol and Macmillan who were
standing there say show us your hands
put your hands up right we don't know
whether Dee alum even understands what
that means at this moment but he's
turned his body away from them he's
reaching for the door and he seems to be
doing something with his right hand and
this starts to get Carol and mcmalley a
little bit nervous because they think
why is he turning his body because he
wants to conceal what he's doing with
his right hand right so they started to
run after him there on the sidewalk and
they boom they go up the steps to go
after to see what he's doing cuz they're
thinking this is getting a little bit
strange and diello
then they look even closer and they see
that what the alley was doing with his
right hand is he's coming he's pulling
out an object out of his coat right they
look at the object only conceals it it's
black they see this little thing coming
out and they start to get even more
concerned and they see the top of this
black object and it's kind of shiny and
they're thinking oh my god God
so Carol yells out God he's got a gun
right but but dal doesn't stop pulling
it out he keeps going pulling it up
pulling it out pulling it out pulling it
out until he's actually Oh pick up and
she's actually pointing it towards them
like this right now Macmillan here is
Carol say he's got a gun any panics he's
on this top step of the vestibule and he
pushes back he jumps backward it gets
terrified he pulls out his gun he starts
firing right now Carol standing right
there and he sees Macmillan fall back
with she thinks oh my god but melons
been hit why else would he fall
backwards and he sees the bullets
ricocheting around this very small
vestibule he thinks oh my god Dell was
firing a gun so he pulls out his gun and
he starts firing boom boom boom back in
the car you've got boss and Murphy and
they see McMillan fall backwards they
think he's been hit man
down jump out of the car and they pull
out their holsters and they their guns
and they start firing right in the ends
Carolyn
McMillan fire 1516 bullets each boss
fires 5 Murphy fires 4 bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang right and as they're
firing it at yellow yellows in the
corner of the vestibule is back as
straight and his knees are bent so
they're thinking classic shooters crouch
right this kid's been trained that's
what they're thinking it's back like
this down here would this thing out in
his hand I think he's trying to make
himself as small as possible so they aim
for center mass which is what you do
when you're confronted with somebody
knows what you're doing so they're all
going bang bang right this guy's chest
seeing their back up against the end of
the vestibule finally they stop he's
down and and Ken boss gets up and he
walks towards diella he looks down his
right hand find out see the gun get the
gun right the palms open he looks down
and there's no gun just a wallet sitting
on the ground he screams where's the
[ __ ] gun right and he starts running
up wheeler Avenue because he's
completely forgotten where they already
he's got to call the ambans he's no idea
where to tell the ambulance to go just
running up and down wheeler Avenue
screaming out where's the [ __ ] gun
then Carroll gets up and he walks
towards Diallo
he looks down and he sits down the steps
next to him he starts to cry and that's
what the ambulance finds when they
arrive now what happened that night
right I was attracted to the story when
I went to write this book because it's
an unusually complicated and ambiguous
story and all the ways I think we had
for explaining it at the time were
deeply unsatisfactory I think back to
when that case was in the news there
were two sides to that story the way it
was told one side said these cops are
racists see a black guy assume he's a
criminal
bang bang bang bang bang 41 bullets
right Bruce Springsteen writes a song
called 41 bullets this is all about how
you can get shot for just for living in
your American skin which was this kind
of reductive notion that that was all
about this instant was all
skin color well I don't denied of skin
color played a role and we'll get back
to that issue later on but to say this
is about opening an open-and-shut case
of racism is absurd everybody in the
South Bronx is black or Hispanic they're
not shooting everybody these call for
cops they shoot one guy doesn't tell us
why they single out that guy also
there's no evidence whatsoever that
these four guys are bad eggs there's
nothing in their past that suggests that
they are vicious or angry or this isn't
like the cop who attacked the I forgot
his name with the plunger yeah
it's nothing like that case these are
actually good kids talk to people who
knew them just they're like good solid
honest not a blemish on their record
that's some quite work and on the other
side there was the whole line which was
the line adopted by the jury which later
acquitted these guys of all charges and
the line adopted by NYPD which was well
it's just one of those things right this
happens it's called police work you know
you get in a situation sometimes and
it's really sad but you make a mistake
and there's nothing much we can do about
it
well that's also deeply unsatisfactory
this isn't just some kind of routine
mistake guy goes out to take in the air
maybe have a cigarette and get shot 41
times by four cops cruising up down the
street there's nothing normal about that
particular event something actually went
wrong so what we need I think is a kind
of third understanding of what happened
that night and I think that the only way
to get at that understanding is to break
down that little incident
second-by-second until we can see all of
the moments the decisions that went into
that particular tragedy and try and
understand how it came about so think
about that this case for a moment there
are three particular moments in that
instant that I think are worthy of
discussion first of all Shawn Carroll
seized Yello
he says to the others in the car what's
that guy doing there right hold up hold
up what's he doing now the answer is
that diello is getting some air he's
totally innocently standing on the front
porch to his own home right but Carroll
looks at him but in that instance
decides he's suspicious
mistake number one he's innocent they
think he's suspicious then they back up
and one of the things that Carol said
that was very interesting was that when
they backed up they saw that Diallo was
still standing there didn't move and
Carol would say later that that amazed
him right why didn't this guy move if
you're standing out there on a street
corner middle of night four cops in an
unmarked car drive past backup towards
you you run that's what everybody else
did
this guy stands there right so point
number two they think oh he's really
brazen this is a really really bad guy
he's completely undeterred by the side
of four monstrous cops he's not a bad
guy though he's not brazen he's curious
he's from Africa he's standing he's only
been in his country a couple months he
sees four white guys in a car backing up
towards him some part of him says whoa
what is this mistake number two confuses
brazenness with curiosity with
brazenness and then Carol and Murphy are
Macmillan are standing on that vestibule
and they watch diello turn to his side
and start to pull something black out of
his coat and that instant they decide
that he's dangerous but he's not
dangerous he's terrified right
mistake number three they mistake
terrified for terrifying now ordinarily
in normal course of our lives we have no
problem with these distinctions we are
really really good at as human beings at
making a distinction between innocence
and suspiciousness of making a
distinction between brazenness and
curiosity and most of all at making a
distinction between terrified and
terrifying you walk down the street the
mill the night you make that those
judgments every single moment when you
see somebody you go boom I'm scared of
him no that person scared of me right
nothing we're better at than doing that
we've been good at that for millions and
millions and millions of years so that's
what's interesting about this case that
in that moment on that street corner on
that street that night they make three
really really basic errors that they
shouldn't have made three errors that
most of us would you know would make
very very rarely in our lifetimes
but they can pound them office so why do
they do that what is it that happened on
that night that caused them to be
somehow fundamentally incapable of
reading the aloes mind because that's
the failure here right they were not
able to get put themselves into diallo
shoes they didn't correctly understand
his intentions in that moment they were
they and as a result they completely
misinterpret what that social situation
is all about they put their own
construction on it that's about a crime
and a criminal instead of it being about
person standing outside getting some
night air now I call this kind of
failure momentary autism and the idea is
that I use that phrase because the
simplest definition of autism is that
autism is autism is a neurological
condition that renders us incapable of
reading someone else's mind right when
we with one another but the the British
psychologist Simon baron-cohen refers to
autism as simply as mind blindness the
inability of people with autism can
listen and understand your words but
they cannot understand any of your
intentions they are incapable of taking
that extra step to interpret what
they're hearing and put it in
appropriate context and what I'm saying
is that there are certain situations
when otherwise normal people become
effectively autistic just in that
particular moment not as a chronic
condition but as an acute condition in a
handful of seconds when they're in
moments of extreme stress and I think
that that is actually a surprisingly
common kind of failure and if we look at
the way the world works or more
accurately does not work we see this
pattern repeated over and over again
that lots of mistakes happen because
there are certain situations which lead
us from an ability to make sense of
intentionality to read other people's
minds into a temporary state we were
incapable of doing that the so what I
want to do is sort of talk about this
concept and then talk about what it
takes to try and prevent these attacks
of momentary autism there's a there's a
really wonderful researcher at Yale
called Amy Klein and I'm inclined or
Clin I'm not sure which one it is I hope
he's not watching has done some really
really fascinating work in trying to
understand and trying to sort of explain
what happens when someone has what it
means to have autism and he has this
patient guy named Peter and he's been
seeing Peter for many years and Peter is
a now I think in his 40s or 50s a very
very intelligent man whole series of
graduate degrees has a job lives on his
own but he has autism and he comes and
sees ami Klein come every week and they
sort of sort out his life an army helps
him make decisions in 2007 I'm not long
ago ami decided to do an experiment with
Peter to try and demonstrate precisely
how Peter makes sense or does not make
sense of social situations and what he
did was he put a pair of goggles on him
and these are these special goggles that
track where your eyes move right and on
that so you when you you can show
somebody something put these goggles on
and actually their eyes will they'll
draw a line on the screen you can see
precisely where their eyes are following
any given time so it put gave Peter
these goggles and he had him watch Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf the movie with
Richard Burton and those with Taylor and
Joycey and he chose that movie for a
reason which is that first of all it's
one of his favorite movies but more
importantly it's a movie about a very
complex social situation right it's
three people in a room I should spoil
her and I've forgotten who the other
actresses thank you
it's four people in a room having this
incredibly fraught interaction over the
course of an evening getting really
drunk getting really upset each other so
there's all kinds of complex dynamics
Tommy said to me that you know he wasn't
going to show Peter Terminator 2 you
know because you know where the actual
gun is the hero or whatever it doesn't
work but it is enough to decode anything
particularly complicated but this would
be a really interesting test of an
extraordinarily sophisticated
interaction among four people how does
Peter make sense of this so what he does
is he has these he shows in this movie
and so Peters you're on the print of the
movie we're seeing where Peters eyes are
moving in any given time and then he
does the same thing with people who
don't have autism
watches where their eyes move so the
scene where Richard Burton and Elizabeth
Taylor are kissing now when you and I
watch this scene what our eyes do is
there hears Burton here's Taylor our
eyes go back and forth between their
eyes goes like this that's what we do
when we watch people kissing in a movie
just look at their eyes because the
truth of everything is in their eyes
right we want to know what kind of kiss
is this what's happening with the kids
are they happy or the excited is one
being forced to kids together all that
information or much of that information
is contained in the eyes so we're going
to do like this what a Peter doing solid
scene he looked at the light switch
behind them now why did he do that
because for someone with autism there is
no special meaning attached to eyes he
can't make sense of the information he
finds in someone's eyes because he can't
read intentions he can't mind read and
as a result there's no particular reason
for him to look at the eyes in a given
scene the thing it's equally interesting
for him to look at the light switch and
as it turns out he's very mechanically
minded Peter and so white swishes Adame
told me really interest him so he was
looking the whole time at the light
switch was another scene where I'm
George Segal points at a painting on the
wall and says who did that painting
right and Richard Burton answers him now
when we watch that scene
our eyes follow the line of George
Siegel's hand till we see the painting
and then our eyes go over to Richard
Burton's eyes to get his to get the
answer and then our eyes come back to
George Segal to see how he reacts to the
answer we form a triangle really quick
in a millisecond boom boom boom boom
right what does Peter do he's listening
he's watching he hears who did that
painting painting but he doesn't follow
the line of the finger of George single
seagulls finger because he can't make
sense of this gesture this gesture means
nothing to someone who can't read minds
to know what I'm what I'm pointing out
on why I'm pointing at it you have to be
able to inhabit my mind for that moment
to understand now why would Malcolm do
that what's the purpose of that Peter
can't do that right so all he has is
this information who did that painting
so he looks at the
all where the painting is but there's
three paintings on the wall not one
so what Peter does is he's going back
and forth frantically among all these
paintings trying to figure out which
painting is being referred to meanwhile
the conversation has already moved on
he's behind he's missed the whole
meaning of of that particular encounter
there's another another even more
poignant scene where Elizabeth Taylor
was flirting with George Segal there's
same flirting going on and the
background Richard Burton is getting
angry or more jealous and angry and more
jealous and when we it's really cool to
look at the way normal viewers look that
scene because you're you're doing the
triangular thing at breakneck speed
you're just going boom boom boom between
three sets of eyes right round and
around and around and around and around
because it's building and building and
building it's an incredibly powerful
scene in this movie I try to understand
it's it's gripping right
what's the mounting emotions and what's
what your Burton gonna do and how dare
she flirt with this man in front of her
husband right it's really really
fascinating what does Peter do Peter
looks at George Siegel's mouth for a
while then he looks at the drink in
George Siegel's hand and then he one
spends a lot of time looking at this
really cool brooch that Elizabeth Taylor
is wearing he can't understand the
social context all he can hear the words
and of course the words had not seen me
nothing the scene about flirting who
cares what's being said it's about the
meaning of these three people
interacting and he misses all that
because he can't mine mine read what
he's left with is it just a little shred
of evidence from that scene and that
little shred of evidence that little
shred of literal evidence what's being
said is wholly insufficient for making
sense of what's happening in the movie
and there's a point in that scene where
it climaxes with Richard Burton a few
people have seen the movie takes out a
gun points at Elizabeth Taylor and pulls
the trigger and an umbrella
pops out of the after and if you sit it
in that in a movie theater watching that
movie at that moment there's a kind of
shocked stunned silence because you're
thinking oh my god right and then the
umbrella comes out you're like what like
this what Peter saw that first felt
laughing why because it's slapstick to
someone who doesn't understand the
social
context of what has gone on in that
movie so you see the inability to read
minds creates an enormous problem when
it comes to making sense of any sort of
fast flowing complex social situation
now I think that this is all a very long
way of saying that I think this is a
very useful and powerful model for
understanding what went on with those
officers that night right they get to
that scene with the other and they are
completely incapable of extracting the
necessary and critical social
information from it they don't get it
they're missing all of these cues right
there like Peter they're seeing some
objective facts right really little
interpretation black eye young guy bad
neighborhood
late at night shiny black object he's a
grand mal he's trying to shoot me right
that's peanut it's a Peter like
interpretation of it right but it misses
all of the nuance that's going on in
that all of these alternate
interpretations that might collar it or
cause you to kind of think twice about
that conclusion all of that is somehow
pushed aside they've locked in on this
extremely narrow and little
interpretation in that moment they are
effectively autistic when they're
standing on the when they're driving in
that car and they're standing on the
steps of the vestibule so the question
is what caused it why would they why
would they turned into the equivalent of
of autistic people at that moment on the
steps now in the in the book I have the
explanation goes on for pages and it's
far more interesting than the
explanation I'll give you now which is
why as I said you should buy the book in
triplicate but um
I'll give you a just a sense of some of
the things that I sort of think about to
try and understand why autism would have
descended on those four guys at that
moment the first issue is the issue of
arousal and that is that what effect
does being physiologically aroused have
in our ability to mind-read you know in
this case we have we have two guys who
are convinced that the person in front
of them is trying to kill them what does
that situation do to your ability to
mind-read to make sense of the social
complexities of the situation
well we know that all kinds of weird
things happen to people when other
people point guns at them and it's not
like the movies where this is handled as
a kind of everyday occurrence if you
read through testimony of particularly
police officers who have been fired upon
or have fired you read you learned that
there's an extraordinary series of
completely bizarre things that happen to
us in that situation for example almost
everyone who's been fired on or his
firing gun describes an extraordinary
moment of tunnel vision basically you
only see what's immediately in front of
you everything else is gone same thing
that happens overwhelmingly is that
people lose their sense of hearing you
don't hear anything this is actually a
huge issue in police shootings because
time and time again police officers
fire their guns more times than they
should right they empty they're gone
into somebody and they should only have
fired once or twice and it always comes
up why did you fire 16 bullets well a
lot of the times and this is always not
taken seriously as an explanation but it
is a completely serious explanation they
keep firing because they can't hear
their gun going off and they think their
guns not working absolutely the case
that we that part of our sensory system
shuts down to that kind of stress
there's a guy named David cling I wrote
this book called into the kill zone
which is just a series of totally
fascinating interviews with police
officers who've been fired on and here's
one I'm gonna read from one of them
which i think is really interesting it's
about a a police officers partner guy
named Dan is wrestling with a criminal
and the officer is like trying to he's
about this criminals trying to kill his
partner Dan and he's trying to kill the
criminal before he kills Dan
this all happened real fast in
milliseconds and at the same time I was
bringing my gun up Dan was fighting with
him and the only thought that came
through my mind was oh dear God don't
let me hit Dan I fired five rounds my
vision changed as soon as I started to
shoot it went from seeing the whole
picture - just the suspects head
everything else just disappeared I
didn't see Dan anymore didn't see
anything else all I could see was the
suspects head I saw four of my five
rounds hit
the first one hit him on his left
eyebrow it opened up a hole the guy's
head snapped back and he said Oh like oh
you've got me he's still continued to
turn the gun towards me and I fired my
second round I saw a red dot below the
base of his left eye and his head kind
of turned sideways I fired another round
he hit on the outside his left eye and
his left eye exploded just ruptured and
came out my fourth shot hit just in
front of his left ear and he goes on and
on now that's a really really weird
explanation because of course he's
describing something that is not
physiologically possible right you can't
actually observe the actions of bullets
in real time yet he was in that moment
so utterly locked in on this task and
his person in front of him that it
seemed to him as if everything had
slowed down to the point where he could
see the entry of his bullets and the
kind of consequence of of the bullets
hitting this guy's head now it's very
easy to see how important from an
evolutionary perspective this kind of
physiological process is if we are in a
position of extraordinary danger it
makes total sense that our body would
just say look anything that's extraneous
we're not going to worry about I want
you to focus just on the thing in front
of you I'm going to slow things down I'm
going to cut off things like noise which
you don't need at this moment I just
want you to you know one of the things
that people find actually in shootings
in particular in wartime is that an
extraordinary number of people who are
fired upon lose control their bowels
it's rarely remark ton because it's a
little bit unpleasant but it's true for
the simple reason that when your body is
confronted with life-or-death situation
that's not essential it's focusing
instead on the problem at hand and you
know what control of that particular
part of your body is something that we
can worry about later
same thing with car I don't know why I'm
going off on this but car accidents talk
to cops who've done a lot of car
accidents the first thing is the smell
people not into that kind of stress have
shut down various parts of their body
in any case think about that though
taken to an extreme in the beginning
that kind of reaction is enormously
useful but let's push it out a little
bit further
your body's starting to shut down and
according to people sorry this between
about Hartmann to about 115 and 145 all
of these kinds of processes are really
really useless blue useful they help us
zero in on what's going on but when you
get beyond that you start getting up
into 150 175 200 it starts to become a
real problem because you start to get
incapable of any kind of rational
thought and your hearing and your
eyesight shut down to the point where
you're essentially blind and deaf and
your motor coordination starts to really
seriously deteriorate and your behavior
becomes extraordinarily aggressive
you've no more kind of access to any
sort of higher cognitive control right
the this is why police officers will
always tell you that you need to
practice dialing 9-1-1 because an
extraordinary problem with people when
they're in serious trouble is a burglar
in the next room is they can't dial
nine-one-one one is if they can't hit
the buttons on the phone because they
have no coordination left because their
heart rate is 202 is that they can't
remember 911 people who dial for one one
and an accident of 911 is extraordinary
you can't remember it's gone and the
other problems of people never they
forget to press the send button on their
cell phone
you'll dial something and then they just
look at their phone it's not working
like you know all that stuff's gone in
that moment under that extraordinary and
this is why actually why police
departments recently and very belatedly
have started to ban high-speed chases
part of the problem with high-speed
chases is what happens during the chase
right you kill innocent bystanders that
is a serious consideration it is not the
only consideration however the other and
in some ways more important
consideration is what happens after the
chase if you have someone driving at
high speeds
after some suspect in the middle of
residential areas or what have you
their heart rates go crazy the rate of
arousal what's going on with them is
absolutely insane so they get out of the
car
and they're no longer human in a certain
sense they've been turned by the forces
of this psychologic physiological
process into something else entirely
like think about Rodney King had long
discussions I was right
book with these former LAPD officers and
they would say you know everyone said
that was about race and lots and lots of
things that happened with the police in
LA and the public are about race but
this was not about race nothing to do
with race Rodney King could have been as
white as snow and exactly the same thing
would have happened this was about what
happens when you have a group of eight
young men chase another young man
through residential area at 100 miles an
hour for half an hour right you get out
of the car and your heart rates at 200
and you go and you find this guy you
just go crazy on him remember there was
a moment when stacey koon said he go
stacey koon says tells them to stop and
they don't it's a huge issue in the
trial he says stop stop they don't stop
they keep beating Rodney King it's
because they don't hear him hearings
gone first thing that went was hearing
they're completely oblivious to anyone
shouting any kind of direction or
instruction in that moment because
they're in that moment they're out of
their mind now there's a there's a one
of the cases that really broke my heart
like this is it's a case a couple years
ago in Chicago with a guy named Russ
Russ was a kid he was doing he was a
college student he's driving through
Chicago he makes her illegal u-turn cops
see him and come after him right but he
doesn't stop so they have a chase gets
onto the Dan Ryan I think finally they
cut him off and he's like it's either
Road cops jump out and they say get out
of the car doesn't get out of the car
and so the cop starts running towards
the car and smashes the back window of
the car sticks his gun in says that Russ
went after his gun we don't know if it's
true shoots him Russ is dead right now
it's a completely heartbreaking case
right it's really really really bad
police work it's also though a classic
example of what happens in these chases
people forget all sins and what exactly
is going on there the police officer in
that moment in order to successfully
resolve that situation must engage in a
kind of mind-reading he must understand
this whole situation from Russ's
perspective Russ as a kid Russ did
something really stupid and illegal
u-turn in front of a cop then the cops
came after him what it Russ do he
panicked
our kid right he's never been in this
situation before he goes in this kind of
chase and finally they cut him off in
sin credit his his heart rate is going
crazy they yell get out of the car go he
can't hear them of course he's
completely raw so he's sitting there
terrified and this cop comes up behind
him smashes the window and sticks a gun
in his face boom he's dead what that cop
lost in that moment what he lost his
result of his erotic arousal was any
ability to interpret the meaning of that
event in a sophisticated way he lost any
sense of the social context of that
event he lost his ability to mind-read
at the moment when he smashes the window
and sticks his gun in he's effectively
autistic that's a very important lesson
in trying to understand what happened
there's another key element here and
that's the element of time I think that
we lose our ability to mind-read when we
run out of time which is a very obvious
point but I think it's worth coming and
getting into in more detail this is a
huge element in any kind of deadly
encounter and we forget this because
we're used to
again Hollywood depictions of shootouts
right and in the movies or in a
television show there's two cops they're
firing and they talk to each other and
the victim you know the person they're
firing at shouts out some challenge and
they fire again and they roll arena and
the whole thing takes 20 minutes right
this never happens in the real world
there's a guy named Gavin de Becker who
wrote this wonderful book if gift of
fear a couple years ago he runs a
bodyguard security agency out in LA I
had a long talk with him because he's um
he's studied assassinations he's become
a student of his assassination through
history he has all these tapes
I think Savannah Liza's them he showed
me the tape of the Reagan assassination
attempt in 81 right March of 81 outside
the Washington Hilton Reagan's coming
out of his speech ways the crowd they'll
go Reagan Reagan Reagan right
this kid Robert Hinckley the 22 in his
hand leans in six shots right it's the
police officer hits The Secret Service
guy hits James Brady in the head hits
the car it's Reagan in the lone now the
big question with that is how does he
get six shots off
and thought about that Regan's
surrounded by bodyguards this guy pokes
a gun in shoots six times before they
can rest them to the ground he's right
there
right he's this far from Regan how does
that happen well the answer is it
happens because that whole thing was
over in a blink of an eye you know how
long that whole incident was from the
moment Hinckley's gun is visible to the
moment Hank please on the ground you
know how long it was 1.8 seconds done
juvenille I'm to make sense of that
situation to mind-read Hinckley to look
at the crowd and think who's a threat
who's not a threat whose terrifying
who's terrified right no time whatsoever
1.8 seconds with a shooting a the
saddest nation attempt to the president
of South Korea a couple years ago guys
giving a speech assassins in the crowd
assassin stands up takes his gun out
he's so nervous he starts off by
shooting himself in the foot - goes boom
then he goes and he points at the at the
president and he fires a shot he misses
and he hits president's wife in the head
she falls over dead bodyguard gets up
pulls out his gun shoots hits a
six-year-old kid who's standing next to
the assassin the crowd grabs the guy
they rests them to the ground beginning
to end 3.5 seconds don't right who could
make sense of that no one could make
sense event everything's happened too
fast and when things happen too fast we
lose our higher faculties we lose our
ability to make to do any kind of
sophisticated reading of what's going on
in front of us there's a really um a guy
named psychologist named Keith Payne who
did a beautiful little experiment based
on his a couple years ago and was
inspired by the Diallo shooting and that
is he sits you down in front of a
computer and he flashed Cristina's as he
flashes a black face a plates of a young
black male on the computer screen in
front of you and then he says to you
beforehand he says I'm going to show you
this black face and I'm going to give
you is going to be one of two objects
will appear on the screen either a
wrench or gun and if it's a wrench you
want you to hit this key and if it's a
gunner when you hit this key right
question is how often do you make the
diello error do you hit the button for a
gun when it's the wrench right and the
answer is you make it quite a lot and
you can do all kinds of cool things with
this whereas if you flash a white face
first they don't make the dll error
quite as easily so race clearly plays a
role in the sense of but that's not the
interesting finding the interesting
finding is that the more you speed the
process up the less time you give
somebody to think about their choice
wrench gun wrench gun wrench gun the
more likely they are just to say gun to
the point where you speed it up fast
enough isn't matter how many times you
show the wrench they'll always say gun
gun gun gun gun right black face gun
boom when you speed things up people no
longer try to make sense of it they just
retreat to the most basic most simple
and most in the end destructive
assumption they have time only to say
look it's a black guy chances are he's
got a gun I'm just going to say gun when
times Pizza so you see how that element
of time erodes our ability to do any
kind of clearer and more sophisticated
analysis of the situation the UM this is
why Police Department's if you look at
the way they trained police officers are
obsessed with time all that time right
when you train police officers they talk
endlessly about the need for cover and
concealment you're confronting a suspect
the first thing you do is to look is to
look for some way either to be out of
the suspect line-of-sight or just even
to obscure yourself in some way now why
is that one it keeps you safer but more
importantly it buys you time it means
you're never in a situation of standing
in front of that person and having to
make a decision in a millisecond about
whether to fire or not right you're off
by yourself that person can't hit you so
you can slow things down and think and
say okay I do this so I need to do this
sir that's why in the case of traffic
stops there's a whole procedure the
traffic stop when you're the cop pulls
you over and then he walks up right he
parks his car slightly outside of yours
he walks up along the passenger side on
the driver's side and he always stops
behind your head ever notice that's not
supposed to stop in front of you behind
you
shined his flashlight over
your shoulder why is he doing that
because if you've got a gun he slowed
the situation down in order to shoot him
if you've got a gun you've got to take
the gun twist your body right around
your seat you got a seat belts nearly
impossible poke it through the kind of
window the back and shoot him that takes
time if he's standing in front of you
you just go boom by doing that he has
helped to save your life in a certain
sense he has tried to introduce an extra
couple of seconds that allows him to
make a much more sophisticated analysis
of what's going on body guys the same
way after the Reagan sure the problem
with the Reagan shooting the reason
Reagan got shot is there was no whites I
call it white space in the bodyguard
business there was no space around
Reagan you must have a protective kind
of area where there's no people of 10 or
15 or 20 feet at any given time around
someone who you want to keep safe why
because the greater the amount of space
there is between any potential assailant
and a target the more time any kind of
action aggressive action is going to
take and time means safety in that
situation time gives the bodyguards the
ability to scan the crowd and get a kind
of understanding of who might be
dangerous and who might not be this is
also why there's been such a push in
recent years I'm in police departments
to replace two-man cars with one-man
cars and that seems really kind of
intuitive and people often look at this
and say oh they're just trying to save
money doesn't get with money has to do
with time if you do is all kinds of
research that shows that to officer cars
get into far more trouble end up
shooting far more innocent people end up
beating up far more people end up doing
all kinds of bad things far more than
officers who are traveling by themselves
and the reason is that when you're with
someone else you speed things up you
have the kind of social courage to rush
in and if you by yourself you'd never do
that in a million years you'd stay pew
stay behind and you call for help and as
a result something that might have been
accelerated gets decelerated and as a
result someone who might lose their life
in the end gets to save their life now
the significance of all this I think is
that it's a reminder of how impoverished
our vocabulary is for describing
failures for describing sasser's for
six and accidents you know we have this
very very simplistic way of trying to
make sense of why things went wrong we
look at Rodney King and we say that's
about a bunch of racist cops well
actually no it's about what happens when
you chase someone for an hour 200 miles
an hour right that's a far more useful
way of understanding that particular
problem we look at that cop who rushes
up after Russ and bangs the window and
sticks his gun and we say what a
terrible you know awful person that cop
is he should be in jail well yeah he is
a terrible awful person in some sense
but maybe he was really badly trained
totally at some point in his life it was
not drilled into him that when you do it
when you're in that kind of situation
you stand by your vehicle undercover and
call out to the person to get out of the
car right is that training or is that
fall to the person well maybe it's a
little bit of both the most of all when
we look at these kinds of social
blunders because all of these things
I've been describing are in certain
sense social blunders their social
blunders by people who happen to have
guns in their hands when we look at
these things that people go wrong at the
kind of cues that they miss we forget
that the kind of skills that we have
that make us human that allow us to
function intelligently in the world are
really really fragile they're not always
there with us and there are
circumstances when these kinds of very
very powerful and critical skills can be
obliterated circumstances that can read
take us from being sophisticated to
being extraordinarily unsophisticated
from take us from take to take us from
being capable of mind-reading to being
functionally in that moment autistic so
to go back to the yellow there they were
right Sean Carroll can boss ed McMullen
and Richard Murphy it's late doing Bronx
South Bronx I see a young black man he
seems to be behaving oddly it's like
standing what's he doing out it's
February what's he doing outside they're
driving they can't see him all that well
they're kind of cruising by but right
away they construct the kind of system
it's kind of a rigid system
well black guy late 12:30
can't be good right he's small too I'm
blessed he was five foot six what a
small mean at 12:30 at night in the
South Bronx
means you've got a gun right he's not
out there by himself at that size unless
he's got since he's packing right that's
the first thing they're thinking thank
you gone right totally right this guy's
got a gun then they back up and he
doesn't move so now you know they're
thinking oh my god not only is he a gun
this guy isn't badass he's completely
not scared by the cops Wow so now
they're kind of dander is up even more
so now they're like say get out of the
car right and McMullen says
Carroll says police officer we have a
word right and Dale turns and he runs
back in the building because he's
totally and utterly terrified four big
white guys in the South Bronx late at
night coming after him with their chest
puffed out with their bulletproof vests
right but they don't have time to kind
of think through all this because it's a
pursuit right he's running back into the
building like boom
chase and what happens when chases start
well your heart rate soars these guys
aren't seasoned professionals who
business before they're raw they're new
to the Bronx so like their heart rate
goes from 100 or 115 to 150 160 170 200
they're bounding up the steps after him
I know D I was in the at the door at the
back of the vestibule he's turned his
body somewhere he's tugging at something
this waistband right but Carolyn
McMullen don't have any cover no
concealment no way to slow this down to
right in front of him and he's it's a
narrow vegetable they're here he's here
no space whatsoever no chance to kind of
figure out what is that black thing in
fact things are getting faster and
faster
now it's a wallet it's not a gun but
think about it DL is black and we're
measuring this in milliseconds and
whenever you have to make a decision
about a black person in a few
milliseconds you think it's a gun you
always think it's a gun you go online
and do which it pains experiments
everyone in this room will say gun in
that situation right and he's not
Carol's not mine who to get alright now
he's completely autistic he's locked in
on this object the same way that Peter
was locked in on the light switch in
that scene right so yells he's got a gun
he's got a gun and then McMullen panics
and jumps backwards and starts firing
and you know someone jumping backwards
in that situation means only one thing
he's been shot
so can Boston and I'm Richard Murphy
jump out of the car and they start
firing - now the next day in the papers
and four months afterwards a huge amount
is always made of the fact that 41
bullets are fired well you know 41
bullets can be fired by people with
semi-automatic pistols in two seconds
three seconds it's not a significant
number if you're in that degree of
excitement in fact this entire incident
probably takes place from beginning to
end in no more than about six or seven
seconds right caramel and stop the car
and call out to Diallo peace officers we
have a word thousand one right Diallo
turns runs back in the building they
jumped towards a thousand and two right
he yells he reaches into his pocket to
get something comes out what's a little
black thousand and three Carol goes he's
got a gun thousand four right shooting
starts thousand five thousand and six
silence Ken boss gets up walks towards
the yellow on the ground looks down at
his hand and tries to see where the gun
is that he sees a wallet he goes where
is the [ __ ] gun thousand seven
thousand and eight he runs up the street
because he's completely forgotten where
they are and then Sean Carroll goes and
sits down steps and starts to cry
thousand nine thousand and ten and
that's the end of um do deal thank you
so I'd now sorry to find out that you
down hi hi so what does this information
tell us about I'm not trying to make
this political but what does it tell us
about trying to win the war in Iraq with
19 year old kids in a foreign culture uh
well um I hesitate to give any kind of
global interpretation of this because I
said I'm not interested deliberately
uninterested in this book in grand
themes I will say that it can teach us a
lot about those instantaneous moments
when things go wrong in war there was a
moment in this war whether a lot of
these cases where there's a checkpoint
and you're supposed to stop at the
checkpoint and the car comes the
checkpoint with full of Iraqis and it
doesn't stop and then they open fire and
everybody dies right and it's a classic
case of that that there's no there needs
to be some way to slow things down in
that situation that the the 19 year old
private who two months ago was you know
in Kentucky somewhere has to decide in
that moment whether the people in front
of them are a car bomb or just an
innocent family out for Drive who don't
understand that the instruction to stop
their car and that kind of thing will
inevitably lead to heartbreak unless we
change the situation in such a way to
allow there to be an extra couple of
beats and so there can be some kind of
mind-reading of whoever's is approaching
and there's lots of ideas going on now
and police work about trying to slow
things down I mean a lot of us move
towards non-lethal guns for cops it's
about that so if you absolutely have to
make a split-second decision you're not
sure about it you don't kill the person
you just knock them down and that's I
think a really not a good way of coming
to terms with that may I ask two
questions are you dear plans to address
any law enforcement groups or military
groups with this information um well no
one I mean the books not out yet but I
you know if if people would like me to
I'd love to
this is not um there's been a lot of
work I mean I'm not telling them
something they don't know there's been a
lot of work on this in the last couple
of years in the law enforcement
community in thinking really hard and
cops there is a reason why accidental
shootings for example I'm in major
police departments in the country are
lower today than they were in the past
and that is the people have begun to
take these lessons to heart and training
for police officers has changed
dramatically over the last 20 years it's
not far from perfect and it's not as
good in other parts of the country as it
is in New York City but it's getting a
lot better and so there was a real
awareness of these issues just hearing
you talk made me think about people who
are raised in a culture of fear and how
it could inhibit creative thought if you
were raised in that culture and yeah um
I was raised in a family where there was
fear was just a common response to
things as an adult I've had to learn how
to slow down because I can't I'm not
I'll of the word I have a new word I'm
autistic when I'm trying to yeah you
know and so I wonder if looking into
this if you've thought about
applications to less dramatically
extreme moments and I don't know you
meditate for instance having you know
done all this work yeah no it's a very
it is as with all things with all books
that once you're finished people tell
you all kinds of wonderful ideas for the
way you ought to written the book and
you've you've just done that yeah
sure you described the ability to
interpret the scene scenes for example
in Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf
happening in milliseconds but I take it
the audience the viewer can do this
because they're not adrenaline loaded
mm-hmm and not hyper heart rated so I
was wondering if the application of your
of your thesis is is only - or perhaps
there's no application to anything that
isn't adrenaline-fueled there's no way
to speed up the capacity to do the
mind-reading yeah well it's most
interesting I mean that in the chapter
in the book on mind-reading I limit
myself to these kinds of sped up
situations these kinds of very very
stressful situations because I think
that's where the application is clearest
but I think it's the previous speaker
pointed out I think there are you can
sort of play with this idea in all kinds
of other contexts but I haven't and
perhaps should have but um the but I
think you know that there are far more
cases where we are in these stressful
situations than we think it's not just
police officers you know anyone who has
driven a car has moments where they're
in situations where things are speed up
sped up too much and adrenaline is
racing or so I think there is a kind of
wider applicability of some of these
ideas to everyday life they're just
easiest to see and you know we get so
consiglio are enormously important
because they are there are culturally
significant events that come to define
the way we think about ourselves the way
we talk about things like race the way
we address problems of law enforcement
so they're not trivial they're not these
kind of isolated they really impact the
way we set about to to construct our
society and so I think it's important
for us to think about the Minnesota's to
get away aria
I like the the idea of the autism in
momentary autism one of the things that
you described it as autistic is the
inability to read another person
basically through the eyes as a key
thing that you mentioned wasn't there
something in the Diallo case about the
darkness of the vestibule and the cops
inability to see his eyes and is that
mm-hmm tied in with this autistic
response if we gal see a person's eyes
I'm absolutely um two things so I
realized I should never have had an Amen
um it was just so tempting uh there's a
weird thing about the way they teach
police officers one things I teach them
is to always look at the hands so
there's a little element of training
there where they are in many ways taught
to avoid the very thing that can tell
them a lot and there's a reason it means
a very complicated argument about where
you ought to be looking in those
critical moments the hands certainly
tell you you know whether there's going
to be a weapon available but as we can
as we can see weapon is a very is itself
an ambiguous you know if wallets can
look like guns under the right
circumstances then maybe the eyes are
more important than the hands but
certainly it was dark so even if they
had but so I think that they're looking
at his hands to begin with and so even
if it would been perfectly light out
they would have missed a lot of the
evidence of the eyes but in this case it
was dark and I think that does harm
things a bit particularly when they're
driving past the first time they can't
see innocence is something that we
interpret from a lot of things from
people's eyes people's demeanor the way
they're standing and they're driving
back in it's dark out so they don't have
a lot of these visual cues that we
normally use to make that initial
assessment of whether someone is a
threat or someone is harmless so the
darkness plays a big big role and also
the darkness helps them jump to this
conclusion that he's this kind of badass
right because it's 12:30 I mean they
don't think that if it's 12:00 noon
so that I think that darkness is a bad
gun sure hi I've read blink already
loved it that's the now that I have two
positive and one yeah
and one of the things I found so
interesting in it was the art experts
that were able to spot a forgery
immediately and this was after the Getty
Museum had already bought it and in in a
way it's sort of almost the opposite
kind of example where somebody can make
the right decision very quickly and very
unconsciously because of their expertise
could you just talk a little about that
yeah the book um without giving away
huge chunks of it because I realized the
longer I talk about it the more I
diminish your incentive to buy those
three copies but um I'm interested in
the two sides of snap judgments the fact
that they are under sun circumstances
extraordinarily good and I tell this
long story about a statue at the Getty
on which the Getty bought in 1980 1990
which was turned to be fake
they spent ten million dollars on it and
they analyzed it for 14 months and then
they showed it to all if he brought in
it was a Kouros it was a one of those
Greek marble Greek statues of a boy and
they were given it by this artillery and
bachina
and it was you know there was a 200 Koro
karai around the world and most of them
are quite in poor shape and this one was
in beautiful shape and you know they're
just starting out as a museum and they
were like oh my god this is an
extraordinary thing and they they took
it and they analyzed what we're going to
be very clear this is not a fake so
we're going to take it on loan for a
year and put it through all the paces
and so they brought in the geologists
and the archaeologists and the experts
on this and that and there's a paper
published in Scientific American by one
of the lead geologists analyzing the
proving why that marble was 2,000 years
old and they're so happy and they buy
for ten million and they it's down in
the basement in their restoration studio
and so happens this woman named Helen
Harrison who was one of the world's
foremost experts on Greek sculpture
she's visiting and so the curator Arthur
Houghton says Ellen I've got something
to show you
to come with me I go down the stair
they go to this you know darkened room
he turns on the light and statues
sitting at seven feet high right he
whisks off the cloth he says look at
that you know it's gonna be ours in like
two weeks and she goes oh I'm sorry to
hear that
because what juice fake right like I
don't know no Evelyn yet her mine doula
two weeks later Thomas Hoving member
Thomas Hoving from the met also a Greek
expert a Greek sculpture expert he comes
to visit
Houghton says Tom I got sunny Michelle
takes him down whisks off the cloth and
Hogan Austin goes has a check beard is
it too late to stop it fake so then they
take it to Greece and they have like
room full just like this full of like
all the top Greek guys right you like no
they're sculpture and they whisk the
cloth off everyone's like yeah where'd
you get Gus ting like a FAC one of the
guys says it's like a delaila
he was hit by a wave of intuitive
repulsion so they're like oh my god
right so it turns out it's fake you know
it's it's not 2000 years old and they
bust some guy at the airport and they
find some plaster cast and the plaster
cast is like exactly like this karoku
rose and it's not 2000 years old it was
you know the plaster cast dates from
milan in 1979 and today if you look in
the getty catalog there's a picture the
charoset says either 636 bc or 1980 my
favorite huh but um so there's a case
where like the snap judgments really
really good right and so I spent the
book is goes back and forth and says
well no when are they good and when are
they bad and what are the circumstances
under which what so what are the things
that destroy this what is inherently a
very very powerful tool that we have to
make sense of our society of our world
right so when is it break down and so
that's why I'm so interested in the cops
because normally they've got no problem
you structure that situation right Del's
still alive today right they look at him
and I go oh what are you doing out here
right that's the way or show us your
hands and bl puts his hands up where he
goes for his wallet they said we don't
want your wallet we want it you know
that's
this under normal circumstance that that
works and it works because they look at
him and I go he's just some kid right
but because of all these strange things
have falls apart and the book is a lot
of the book is concerned with
discovering what causes this normally
extraordinary faculty to fall apart and
I talk about cops I actually talk about
situations where really good cops in
that moment are capable of making
extraordinarily sophisticated judgments
because they're very very well trained
and I have a story about a cop who
confronts a kid and the kid is pulling a
gun on him
it's like fifteen years old they're like
face-to-face kids got a gun the cops got
is gonna like this he's like don't pull
a gun on me and the kids pulling it he's
pulling it he's pulling it and a cop
waits cuz he looks into his eyes and he
says I don't think this kid's bad he
waits the kid goes uh-oh
he drops it doesn't shoot um that is
someone who's extraordinarily well
trained and experienced in that moment
but anyway so next like the previous
speaker eyeballs a red blink it's
excellent
I enjoyed it anyone four to one and I
like um I really enjoyed um also like
she did the stories that talked about
indicators you know key bits of
information that you can focus on and
make a snap judgment of course he now
agreed to know how to use that so I did
recollect from you talking about the
tipping point that there were so many
people that you interviewed they
couldn't all make it into the book
it couldn't all necessarily fit either
with your argument and I kind of
wondered about one or two of those
stories that you were curious about that
you pursued and then eventually didn't
make it in oh well I've already um you
mean you want to know about the kind of
via the what do they call it in the
movie business the outtakes well I've
been publishing all my outtakes
that's a joke where's Henry no I am
that's not true uh I you know I'm pretty
efficient I'm an old newspaper guy and
one of the first things they teach you
in these people world is use your entire
notebook so I pretty much use my entire
notebook um the only thing that I didn't
do which I'm going to do is I was really
interested in magic talking about magic
and I'm going to write uh something for
The New Yorker on that that was anything
that I thought of putting in and didn't
but I know I kind of I don't have a lot
of stuff that was left out
I'm with having a little problem with
the term mind-reading that you used a
lot and I'm assuming since you just said
there was actually a chapter in the book
that was mind-reading that it really
plays a prominent role because it's not
really it seemed to me that it wasn't
really the mind that we were reading but
the cues and the signals that most of us
are able to learn but those with mild
autism and different levels of autism
are unable to learn about that I mean
it's not really the mind that we're
reading well we're you're right um we
can't read minds
literally but what we're reading is
intentions I guess and mind-reading is
just is a phrase that's used to describe
the process of inferring intentions so
when I point at this all of you in this
room know that I'm pointing at the
camera now can you look inside my head
and see that it says camera pointing no
but you can infer an intention from my
hand my eyes my tone of voice what I'm
you know all this kind of stuff you can
put together so you're right we're it's
what we're doing is we're we are
assembling and making sense of a whole
group of external cues and drawing what
is often a remarkably accurate inference
about what's going on behind the mind
yeah yeah but if yeah though it's
important to distinguish between those
kinds of inferences and the evidence of
language because you know Peter knows
that they're talking about a painting
Peter is a very Peters got an IQ of 150
Peter is no dummy
but Peter can't make this kind of he
can't interpret this shift something as
simple as this gesture so it is it does
go to something about his inability to
put himself in the mind of someone else
perhaps that's the best way of saying it
you need to be able to imagine yourself
in the shoes of the person that you're
observing or conversing with and that's
what Peter can't do and that's what we
can't do when we're in these traumatic
situations sure you mentioned a couple
of times that the Diallo case was not
about racism but looking at the
experiment in which the white face even
speeded up does not yield the same
results as the black face made up that
says to me that in fact this is
fundamentally about racism and the fact
that it's a subconscious deeply
ingrained automatic first response kind
of racism doesn't make it less troubling
in fact I think in many ways it makes it
more troubling than a kind of KKK
obvious kind of racism that says that
there's something rotten at the core of
our entire society that we need to deal
with and not just by better training but
by fundamentally changing the way we
think well I have to you're right you're
quite right I have two responses to that
I have in the book that chapter another
chapter a long discussion of precisely
that point that what that there are two
kinds of racism conscious racism and
unconscious racism and I had give
everyone a little test and you can all
you know figure out what your levels are
and they are profoundly disconnected
phenomenon so I can be on a conscious
level an extraordinarily unbiased person
and get on a conscious level my behavior
can be profoundly influenced by a series
of of discriminatory impulses that lie
below the surface so you're up to you
right and that's what's going on in a
certain sense that is a powerful
contribu
to refactor in that situation that that
whole sequence they construct it raises
a powerful you know the fact that he's a
young man very important the fact that
South Bronx very important the fact that
it's 12:30 at night very important the
fact that he's black very very important
in that sense you're absolutely right
however we just point it is not the
scent what I mean to say is it is not
the only or the central factor in
understanding that in other words once
we identify racism as a contributory
cause we can't stop right it's wrong to
say it's just about race well no it's
not about race it's about race and this
and this and this and things speeding up
and you can also construct a scenario
where that same thing happens that is
not black right it's Park Avenue its
86th and park it's one o'clock at night
two o'clock at night say two o'clock in
the morning for cops driving down 86th
Street and then one of the service set
entrance they see a guy right back in
the with his you know going like this
they drive by and he Peaks around like
the allah does puts his head back in
they stop the car and they back up what
if the guy do turns around grabs the
through the door goes to was to a thing
that Brit the fact that he's white
you know I don't know how much that
saves them you can construct a scenario
where the cops would have gone down that
pathway regardless of the color of the
man's skin now I think it's much more
likely to happen with a black person in
that since you're right but it could
have happened without a black you know
same with Rodney King in a sense Rodney
King could have been white now you know
that could very well that happens with
white people all the time at the end of
chases so it's so I think you're right
but I think it's important to stress
that it's it is a powerful contributory
factor and not a sufficient factor for
these things to happen
I also enjoyed blink but you know the
samples a little biased I'll just say it
but waiting for you to address the issue
of the role of desire in the intention
of the police officers in the Diallo
case for example or the idea that we see
what we want to see or that we create
our own realities over and over and over
and I found that I was surprised that
you didn't include that yeah there's
more remember this is a chapters this
long and my talk was this long so
there's a little more of that in the
book um the you right I mean there's a
certain that we can do another kind of
analysis we can say what is the context
in which those four guys are operating
it's 1999
and they have been they are in the midst
of the most triumphant season in the
NYPD's history they have conquered crime
in New York and it's an extraordinary
achievement right and they've been told
correctly that the reason they've
conquered crime over the last four or
five years is that they have become far
more aggressive and active right the
reason that it was drummed into police
in this city and now around the country
in the 1990s correctly that you cannot
be ineffective
you cannot effectively enforce the law
if you are if you are passive as a
police department that's what they're
operating it they're operating in a
situation that says you got to be
aggressive then they're put into the
street crime unit what is the street
crime unit it is that part of the NYPD
that's supposed to be even more
aggressive it's proactive you go into
the community you prowl and down when
you see something you stop and you say
what's up what's going on with that
right that's what they were taught they
were taught to be the ones asking the
tough questions the hell is that guy
doing out there at 12:30 right ten years
ago or 15 years ago
please didn't do that that was not the
culture of the police department you
drove on so there is a kind of this kind
of institutional desire you're
absolutely right is a very powerful part
of that that what we are seeing is the
kind of flipside of this of this what I
think in many ways was a positive change
in law enforcement culture but it has
these it gets you into trouble if you
don't
you know correctly observe you know the
proper ways of approaching a suspect or
you don't have guides who are
well-trained these guys are not well
trained right shouldn't been in a street
crime unit but dude but right there is a
kind of um they were they were
influenced by the kind of overall
environment which NYPD was operating
thank you thank you hi I must say I read
blank also and I loved it oh I truly
loved it I must tell you when I read
page 53 I started crying and um the
whole lockdoor concept when you know you
know I mean it was so powerful do you
think that you are touching spirit
you're moving to coming out of the
intellect more into a spiritual realm
and you're almost bringing spirit to the
masses and the young lady that asks the
first question when she spoke about
meditation because it ordered to be
intuitive like you're talking about you
really have to be very quiet and you
have to get out of the intellect and how
do we get quiet how do we not speed up
that time isn't to meditate and is it
this message that you're bringing and I
am certainly so pleased to hear this and
I don't even know if know if you know
what you're doing I probably god that's
been said many times man but I just want
you to know that I know that I know that
you are indeed a master you probably
don't even know it and thank you so much
for bringing your work oh absolutely
love you thank you very much
no I one of the things that motivated
writing the book was the sense that we
have become infatuated with the results
of a certain kind of thinking deliberate
thinking and we have become I think
dismissive of another kind of thinking
and I think it's very very important to
describe these kinds of snap judgments
it's thinking it's not when we say it's
gut feeling or often that's a way of
thinking that it's of dismissing it and
saying that it's a second order kind of
cognition it's not it is every bit as
critical and in every bit as rational in
a certain sense as the kind of thinking
we do that takes place over a long
period of time and involves very kind of
conscious deliver
and so I wanted to kind of privilege
this other kind of thinking and um so
I'm glad to hear that to at least five
of you I have um executed
make it six uh but I did not orchestrate
those let me to say that I have nothing
to do with uh when I read the book I
felt like the the last chapter which you
pretty much described today was a more
reactive situation where you reacted and
maybe not most positively whereas the
first of the book when you described
thin slicing it was a proactive way to
use a quick judgment and I was wondering
if you would talk about how you chose
the term thin slicing and put it in a
nutshell force yeah thin slicing is a
big theme of this book and it describes
the it describes the process by which we
reach conclusions based on very very
thin slices of experience and so if you
look at a lot of very very complicated
decisions that people make it is
possible to reach a profound conclusion
a sophisticated conclusion based on far
less information than you think
you would think going in so I spent a
lot of time for example talking about a
guy who is who is able to diagnose with
uncanny accuracy 95% plus whether a
couple will be together or not 15 years
in the future based on 15 minutes of
conversation with them right tiny tiny
tiny thin slice of that couple allows
him to make an extraordinarily accurate
and meaningful prediction about the
state of their marriage that is not an
anomalous situation time and time again
if you look closely about how
predictions are made you can see that
there are a very very small number of
variables taking place over a very short
period of time that can be enormous ly
predictive of any kind of future outcome
now that process described with the
marriage is a kind of formal you know
but I think we do this constantly where
we're constantly making very searching
and reaching conclusions based on
extremely thin slices right you meet
somebody you know you go on a date you
know you
oh that's a thin flex you know you don't
know right you you have a job interview
with someone you think that in fact
you're making your decision based on you
know five or six hours of careful blood
you not you make a decision you know
boom right there and then I did a story
a couple years ago for The New Yorker on
this kid kid man at know how you
remember the story about a guy named
Nathan Nathan
Nolan Myers who was a senior at Harvard
who I discovered by some random
processes that everybody was trying to
hire in Silicon Valley so I was talking
to one guy at some company for some
buddies we're talking about hiring Zia
and we we like to be you know for
example we like this kid Nolan Meyers
Adam at Harvard oh that's interesting
then I'm sending another conversation
with someone else to tell the different
company because yeah we really like this
kid Nolan Meyers at Harvard so I kept on
hearing Nolan really just kept on
hearing his name so I called him up when
I had lunch with him in Harvard Square
and he just started listing all of the
people who wanted to hire him including
Steve Ballmer at Microsoft Steve Ballmer
was calling him in his dorm room telling
him that he really had to come to
Microsoft now know Lamar is not the best
student at Harvard solid B student a
really really nice guy after a couple
minutes talking to him I want to iron no
I don't have any thick there need but
there was just something about this guy
and so I call up those people as well
know why did you want to hire me so much
they look he's just exactly we're
looking for how long did it take you to
decide you want to hire them you know
pretty much right away you know walked
in we're just thinking that's what we
want right know Lamar's that's not
that's the way we operate you know we're
we're for better or worse
extraordinarily dependent on information
gathered in that first initial encounter
a nice spend a lot of time in my book
trying to figure out you know when that
kind of thin slicing is justified and
when it becomes problematic because
there are certain things that we pick up
in a moment that are a real problem and
I spend a good deal of time talking
about them and if you read the book
how does your own thin slicing our
intuition operate for you as a writer
and a reporter and can you give examples
maybe you do well I'm the I am the I am
the least intuitive person probably ever
I am
so it doesn't really I'm constantly
missing things that go on in the moment
and discovering them only much later
when editor or someone else says know
what about that I go well yeah that
right I am my father is a mathematician
and he is very firmly in the camp of the
deliberate national side and I take
after him I'm afraid so this book was
written from the perspective not of an
insider but as an outsider to these
processes um I am a I am a tourist in
the land of the intuitive sure I very
nearly got a hold of a book if I had
read it I would have loved it how did
you guys how'd you guys find this book
sending it out okay expel America
shikaka
we had big piles of it my time I got
there was a con so anyway um there's big
exam I had to take in medical school and
it was important and I knew I sometimes
got worked up about these things so I
took this bull drug called propranolol
which you can get very easily from any
doctor it's perfectly safe so don't look
at me like that and what this does is
under any conditions to make your heart
rate very stable me just did not rise
right and I did okay but not great which
I will choose to blame on the drug but
my question to you is have you looked
into whether what the interaction of
drugs and judgment because I didn't
really feel like it improved my mental
performance even though I was physically
calm and whether this will be applied
professionally to people who need to be
calm oh that's interesting um well I I
suspect that um you know do we want to
be saying do we want to put our police
officers on you know beta-blockers at
all times
I don't know I mean I wonder yeah I mean
I when it comes to pharmaceuticals I've
always prided myself on having an open
mind so you know maybe we ought to try
that I think when I'm told I have five
minutes one last question so all the
pressures on you to a lot of what you're
talking about is people navigating their
way through the world visually so how do
people who are blind navigate third
their way through well that's
interesting and I don't know the answer
to that I suspect that the cues that we
get from the visual cues that we get are
only they're only part of the
information that comes out about
intentionality and that if you're blind
you simply pay more attention to other
aspects tone of voice or you know that I
mean or or I don't know I mean it's a
really good question and I wish you the
most hearing you would really yeah you
know that I do know that for example
when it comes to there was a wonderful
sight years ago that was done of
basically testing people's ability to
mind-read - in this case it was kid
could you successfully detect whether
somebody was lying and people who had
suffered certain kinds of strokes were
remarkably better at detecting lies and
those who had not because by being
deprived of certain faculties they had
been forced to pay much more attention
to some of these nonverbal pieces of
information so there are conditions
there are circumstances where being
having some of your sensory evidence
disabled can lead to an improvement in
your ability to pick up on some of these
these other these other sources of
information well thank you very much
hold on good
you're not thank you and
just motive of being articles coins
prison
a shark
are they
there's a new
Madeline question surprise you can turn
back
watch it five rotten fish
discover things
people have better try
truck driver
right
every day
I'm going through
was for more